yeah I was doing karaoke on the YouTube
channel is that what the people want
that's what the people want listen
everyone said I can't sing so it's not
as if I have to worry about my real my
true vocals being put out there into the
public domain
[Music]
walkabout scram of me Josh Smith and
today we are joined by two living
legends of the fashions three don't
buzzwagon Queen Victoria Beckham how are
you guys so much better now you guys are
collaborating on a really exciting
project the Victoria Beckham YouTube
channel
which were all buzzing for but what is
Victoria Beckham the influencer going to
be like I'm going to be the real me and
I have to say I did see one of the
proton of the shelfs let's say one of
the shelves back the other day and you
do really get to see the real me I'm not
being too precious about it you know
sure I looked at it I thought oh should
I take that out I don't like how I look
and then you just think no that's that's
me and I think it's important that
people don't just see you know the
perfect version AAG and it'll be
everything from fashion to beauty little
bits of my family that are with me
everywhere that I go in fact I think
Harper was one of the first people that
the cameraman actually interviewed after
the show really she gave her take on the
lady watching she was ready she's here
she's sporting a blog that has great
isn't it
a cupola Anna yeah just like I know and
she sat next to it I mean how do other
girls can say that an accidental winter
at a fashion show not many and rock the
same haircut yeah who wore it best
and obviously one of the amazing things
about YouTube is its creates so many
amazing communities for Martha Wayne's
groups it sounds like the female
empowerment gave rise all those kind of
things
why is it so important to use these
platforms to serve those kind of
conversations
you know I think it's a great platform
and it's a platform that I haven't done
an enormous amount on it's not a
platform that I knew in an enormous
amount about so it's been great working
with Derek and his team to learn more
and to figure out how that can you you
know that the opportunities that that
will bring for me not just with the
business but you know for me to be able
to communicate and engage with my with
my customer you know and also as well
the sad thing is on these social
platforms online paintsville exists
online police still exist what advice
would you give to anyone who is going
through that kind of thing in their
everyday life just don't look at it I
always think it's really nice to meet
but that's just because I don't read the
horrible things like why would you I
mean that's that's so negative and I
think that for me I always like to put
out a good positive energy and you know
a woman supporting other women I think
that that's very important you know I've
wanted to empower women and young girls
since I was very very young with the
Spice Girls on that message is the same
now but it's empowering women through
beauty and fashion as opposed to music
yeah what do you think men supporting
women as well exactly
working with Victoria on this channel
I've been super impressed at how
diligent she's been and the advice that
she's given and the question that she's
done the advice that she's been giving
is good and what she's saying is honest
and from the heart and true and and that
what we have found works best on YouTube
as being an authentic real person and
believe it or not VB is the realest girl
on the tube real deal
you got on the cheap is the closest I've
been for the chief for a while yeah we
should go maybe that's our fee beyond
the cheese in karaoke on the cheese
anyway look singing the Spice Girls to
my heart's content a whole new franchise
a holding cell for the channel yeah
YouTube gold because also it's amazing
time for your business ten year
anniversary tip you're coming out firing
all cylinders YouTube tick
now you're going into beauty which we
are buzzing about any plot spoilers for
us you know it will be everything from
makeup just pink hair to anything really
that comes under the wellness umbrella
you know I've been do
a lot of research really educating
myself as a consumer I want to know what
in product that doesn't mean that things
can't be active things can be active but
as a woman that was a consumer I think
that everybody needs to know exactly
what they're putting on my skin so I
want to make it a bit of a personal
mission to make that easy for the
consumer to understand what you're in
the product I won't be testing on
animals something else that I feel very
strongly about and also looking at how
sustainable I can make my products as
well not just with what's inside but
obviously packaging as well I have a
strong point of view as a woman I know
what I want in my makeup bag what
skincare do I want yes there's a lot of
things in in the beauty industry that I
do find really quite old-fashioned you
know why is it so confusing for the
consumer why don't people have to let
you know what they're using in products
and what you are putting on your face
could potentially be very damaged very
damaging and very dangerous now also
it's harp arranging your makeup bag
because she is working that new bomb is
she really getting into beauty she loves
beauty I mean you know we like to she
likes to play with makeup and it's a
great thing that you can do you know a
mother-daughter thing that you could do
but she definitely doesn't go out
wearing that that would be a little
inappropriate but you know she also
she's very interested you know what is
what am I using or not just her body but
the shampoos and things like that so I'm
teaching her and it's something that she
feels very strongly about you know and
and the younger generation do care about
that they really do care they care about
the environment they care about what
they're doing on their skin they care
about sustainability and so it's very
important yeah so Harper's like an
environmentalist in the main cane which
is great hotel yeah I hope so
anything well guys I hope you enjoy
tonight
right here we are we are gonna hit the
town
[Music]